the true cost of this pandemic is slowly
becoming clearer not just the number of
lives lost but also the number of
life-saving treatments missed especially
by very sick children and this is what
really worries doctors like Sanjeev
Sharma and his team here at Great Ormond
Street Hospital I think all of us within
pediatrics are very worried about this
the planning that we're doing at the
moment it is complicated by the
uncertainty of whether or not there's
going to be another peek at the
understanding that there may well be a
backlog of cases that we need to clear
it's the secondary consequences of this
pandemic so all those things that we
know are happening but that haven't
presented to healthcare environments
that we're most worried about fear has
kept and is still keeping parents away
but thankfully mum Lorraine overcame her
anxiety about kovat 19 and sought urgent
treatment for her son Shawn suffers from
renal vascular hypertension he's already
lost one kidney and was at risk of
losing the other dick anyway a stuffed
function
[Music]
colostomy
I know the whole Colvin thing was hard
enough and then to need treatment and
the thought of time to travel treatment
that we couldn't get at home you know
that we needed to travel to get us it
was just frightening time it was a
stressful time it wasn't business as
normal here but urgent treatment was
never paused the pandemic has obviously
presented real challenges for Great
Ormond Street Hospital
but the concern was never for the
children who are already here but for
those who aren't the secondary effect of
Kovac nineteen could be devastating
UNICEF thinks millions of children
around the world will be affected by the
secondary impact of kovat nineteen and
that applies to not just poorer
countries but to those with advanced
healthcare systems like ours pediatric
oncologists Mehta your Genson tells me
children will die because of a delay to
their treatments important that we don't
have too much collateral damage that the
children don't die from their cancer
when they are treatable and could be
cured but you know it is they will do
much better if we have them in real time
how big or how damaging do you think the
collateral damage could know it could be
quite quite significant I think if we
don't see the children they will come
with much more advanced disease they may
have a poor prognosis I think we need to
see them as soon as we can and we can
but they need to come to us otherwise we
won't know the dedication of the staff
here helped Great Ormond Street come
through the peak of this pandemic but
they know the impact of kovin nineteen
on Britain sick children
we'll be felt in the weeks and months to
come
Ashish Joshi sky news